brothers and sisters
as you can see we're here with the
security i think i might get serious
uh what's going on why are we here we've
got a debate coming up
yes uh we're here in california um in
sacramento california
yes and we've got debate on wednesday
the 10th
of april 2019. california time
california time but uk
time it's eleven at two a.m yeah yeah so
hijab
uh after a successful debate in new york
you'll be debating an atheist
on the 10th in charlotte california time
6 p.m uk time
11 a.m on the next day 11. don't miss
out in charlotte which is
going to be in uc davis by the way so
for those who are local to the area it's
going to be in uc davis yeah
six o'clock and it's going to be um yeah
it's going to be the babies you made an
atheist and if any any terrorists want
to come we've got a security is going to
be very good security